i'm not taking another bite because i do
not want anything coming out of my tutor
hey i'm tucker and i'm jordan and we're
here tasting three of the worst reviewed
slices of pizza in new york city we're
here to give them a chance at redemption
we're going to keep the names of these
places anonymous unless we think they
deserve a second chance and uh give it a
nice review on yelp it's the second
chance of slice
go to this place if you're on the market
for bowel movements worst beats i've
ever eaten don't do it i mean this one
looks good it's a good crunch
honestly it looks good it looks pretty
good it looks really good
[Music]
it's just burnt on the bottom and the
crust is very thin it also doesn't have
a ton of like flavor you can't really
taste the sauce you can't taste the
sauce at all it's not as bad or dry as
they're saying but that's sure but it's
still not good
i feel bad that the fact that we're
grating the worst
i inhaled a piece of crust i think it's
not as dry as they're saying do you
think it deserves a second transit slice
would i actually go out of my way to get
this no it doesn't deserve a second
transit size what a shame too much
cheese crust is too thin and burnt and
there's not really much flavor other
than that it's pretty good
got a pizza that was so soggy question
mark it was awful couldn't even eat it
it's not great when you hold it up and
it goes almost 90 degrees down yeah
but i don't want to pre-judge the pizza
but it's soggy like look at that
okay it is so soft if i press it in the
indent it's like a tempur-pedic mattress
okay
i got a mouthful of grease also i don't
know if this is fully cooked truly like
chewing on nothing no flavor grease it's
just grease someone's gonna come to new
york and be like i'm so excited to have
pizza and they're gonna have one of
these two slices of pizza and they're
gonna be like new york pizza isn't that
like i don't get it what is this pizza
good for i don't think it's good for
anybody they're absolutely correct about
this pizza being very soggy
maybe it's just the style of pizza too
like the crust is so thin no no
okay anonymous pizzeria b
is
disgusting why did we do that
[Music]
one of the worst slices i've ever had
this place gave me my first ever food
poisoning got two slices and in six
hours my insides were liquefied stay
away unless you want to be on your
toilet for two hours unleashing jet fuel
from your tudor my tudor
and goosebumps from that i don't want to
eat this
last time we did this jordan got food
poisoning i got food poisoning right
after it was great anonymous pizzeria
see let's try it i'm not excited oh
i i feel the cardboard
all right
[Music]
it's weirdly thin is there sauce on this
pizza
there's not sauce there's not cheese
this weird piece of bread it's not even
bread it in fact is cardboard there's no
flavor i'm not taking another bite
because i do not want anything coming
out of my tutor
it looks disgusting
yeah it looks gross it's got a weird
tang in my mouth okay that's the thing
there's not a taste until after the fact
there's like a weird aftertaste yeah i
thought at least one of these would be
good this is horrible now that we have a
baseline of what really bad pizza is why
don't we re-re-evaluate
i think i like it because it's edible
and the other two are not edible i mean
it's the best it's not good i think i
could eat the whole piece of pizza
what did we learn jordan don't go to the
worst reviewed pizza places in new york
i don't feel good right now
i'm not giving these a second chance i
just had a weird burp
a little throw up burp in my mouth
don't feel great
maybe we shouldn't be going for the
absolute bottom of yelp after this we're
gonna have to go get some good pizza
from someone please please and some tums
sorry i have to burp
i didn't do it so oh
you